Here at Intelligent Energy, we know that devices empower us more than ever before.
They allow us to control a drone from the palm of our hands,...
...to make an educated medical decision on the spot,...
...to connect people in meaningful ways.
But what powers our devices?
What happens when the power runs out?
Intelligent Energy is developing embedded fuel cell technology...
...which will have the power to free people from the grid,...
...produce cleaner, more efficient energy with zero emissions,...
...make phones that stay powered for days,...
...laptops that last for weeks,...
...drones that fly for hours.
In a world with uninterrupted connectivity,...
...there's no telling the power we will hold in our hands.